Jurassic Park meant so much of so many
people and had such a huge effect on
people made people want to go into the
business maybe people want to go to that
run to the movies and this film seems to
capture so much of the spirit of that
original and that seemed to be the plan
from the beginning yeah what elements
were are in this movie that you feel
sort of recapture that feeling oh you
know there
this movie does I think a good job at
something that's very difficult there's
a real balancing act with this movie
because you want to honor the first
Jurassic Park and then you want to honor
the franchise but you also want to
create a movie that would stand alone
and isn't just a retelling of the first
movie you know if you want to just watch
the first movie it's a perfect movie and
it holds up and you can go rent it and
watch anytime you want so the challenge
was how do we tell him how do we tell in
another chapter of this that feels fresh
that feels new that introduced
introduces new ideas new themes to an
audience but also one that will honor
the franchise you know and you know pay
homage to it but without lampooning it
will you know it's a very fine and
delicate balance and I think I think we
did a good job of it I think the things
that resonate still from the similar to
the original movie are the are the theme
the theme that is the theme that you
know when man metals with nature for his
own amusement it often can backfire and
so that's something that we focus on but
also we have new themes like you know as
a society or have we become so inundated
with miraculous science and technology
all around us that we're no longer
impressed by things that are amazing you
know how is our relationship with
science changed over the past 20 years
and since Jurassic Park came not only
the original movie but the park itself
and the idea of bringing dinosaurs back
from the dead since that happened has
have our children become disenfranchised
with the dinosaur is it still
captivating and astounding or do we need
to build some
think that's bigger stronger faster with
bigger teeth - you know lure them in I
think it asks a lot of questions and you
mentioned that now the park is open
which was one of the original thoughts
that Steven Spielberg had and yeah Park
runs the moon that was my idea
that wasn't even Steven Spielberg's idea
that's my idea it's a good one thank you
so if you were to go to the park right
now what is there a particular
attraction in the park that would be
your favorite that you would run to and
we see things in this movie this
installment of the franchise that you
could only have dreamed of in the
original one being the Moses or the the
water dinosaur you know it feels similar
to like you know the whale at SeaWorld
or something like that like there's a
giant aquarium you know hundreds of
millions of gallons of water that this
thing lives in so that would be the
first thing I'd probably see it's a good
one now everyone's really excited about
this what do you hope audiences feel or
experience when they see this movie you
know I think I think I just remember one
how I felt as a 13 year old scene is in
the theatre for the first time and I
just hope kids walk away with the same
feeling that I had which is just being
captured having their imagination
tickled and you know hopefully they walk
away with a new love of science and
those what is possible through science
and imagination and I hope because I
remember what it felt like as a kid but
now that I'm a parent I I can imagine
what it would be like to give that gift
to my kids to bring them to the theater
to have that moment that memory sitting
in the theater that the weekend we saw
Jurassic world you know I think a lot of
people are gonna walk away with that
this weekend and that's pretty cool
you